they said it's the 20th anniversary of
john hines first appearance on our show
and i'm like i have no memory of that
why would you remember it yeah how did i
even meet this guy
how did you get booked good to see you
too robin uh
you guys had heard about my jump to
shark website speaking of jump to shark
i got to get this guy in oh there he is
hey john there's my hero john hein man
friends jumped to shark a couple years
ago when when they beat the ross and
rachel thing to death survivor jumped
the shark the first time you saw the
survivor bandana the survivor t-shirt
sopranos is just such a great show for
what it is but when they turn up the
hype machine on it you know that you're
in trouble
i guess you enjoyed the appearance
because i came back a few months later
and i became sort of a recurring guest
and that was yeah 20 years ago
and john was a good guest because john
really you know was well thought out
about when a show
jumped the shark you actually had
theories and had watched every episode
it was good this is a man who judges
straws of course he had
he's a really opinionated guy and i
liked it i liked his delivery
and then you got a job with us but then
while you were working for us you sold
jump the shark your website to tv guide
that's correct
an undisclosed amount you've never
disclosed the amount you sold it for
i have not i've never disclosed it why
is that
it was part of the deal or they would
take back what they gave me so
as much as i'd love to tell you i'm not
going to tell you what is amazing about
that and this happens with so many
companies
they bought the website jump the shark
tv guy did absolutely nothing with it
and let it
you know wither on the vine it was so
frustrating because
i spent every night you know working on
that thing
and they just never dedicated somebody
really full time to it and that was the
key to the whole website you had to be
interact with everyone and stay on top
of things and they just buried it
and when did they stop talking to you
because that's what happens is usually
they then stop taking your phone calls
when they've lost interest well it's
funny rob and like when i signed the
deal
they flew me out to the emmys i did a
thing for tv guide network
and then a few months later you know all
of a sudden my emails they weren't
responding that quickly
and then it was about a year i would say
that by the end that
they were just like we've got it we're
good thank you and
that was that didn't it get so big you
once shot a pilot for a game show at
jump the shark game show
two pilots one was a game show one was a
talk show
neither of which saw the light of day
they loved the idea so much you're
thinking of making it into a tv show
we're gonna do a game show based on the
site
yeah and that's when of course jump the
shark will jump the shark but we'll see
what goes there right yeah that's when
jump to shark will get bad
who hosted the game you no the game show
pilot was hosted by
greg fitzsimmons and it was me and
kathy griffin and that year it was
between
that show and dr phil as to which one
would get on the air
and king world for some reason shows dr
phil how do you play jump to shark game
what were the rules there were three
rounds you had two people competing
against each other
the first round was you'd give an
example like some say
this is when the brady bunch jumped the
shark and you would have to
guess which one it was and then after
that it'd get to a
final round where you would have a topic
like
uh michael jackson and you had 60
seconds to list the number of different
ways michael jackson could have jumped
the shark
jeez that's too hard who the [ __ ] could
win that horrible what a horrible show
[Laughter]
it was too convoluted definitely yeah
did you ever calculate if you held on to
that website and didn't sell the tv
guide do you think you could have made
more money in the long run
yeah with the website you do think you
could i do so do you think it was a
mistake selling on the website
absolutely not yeah it was a right time
it was a good deal i
just joined you guys and i wanted to
dedicate myself full-time
to here i couldn't do both and honestly
i mean i was a vp for princeton review
when i saw jump the shark was always my
side thing it was never my main thing
because this sort of became my
creative outlet versus jump to shark so
the timing was right but yeah i left
i left a lot of zeros on the table
looking back
you